ciao ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovissimo video
[Musica]
innanzitutto devo salutare 3d voi cioè
silvia frigo gara buschini e simo
lombardi se volete essere saldati anche
voi non dovete far altro che seguire le
istruzioni che vi metto alla fine di
questo video
ma passiamo subito al tema del video
come potete vedere si parlerà di natale
il jingle bells no scherzavo
si parla di halloween un fischio di
tantissimi di voi mi hanno chiesto dei
consigli per quanto riguarda un
eventuale travestimento di halloween io
sono stata ore ed ore ed ore a
scervellarmi alla fine ho trovato nei
tre soluzioni migliori da proporvi sono
tre travestimenti pazzeschi facili da
realizzare e super economici
meglio di così non si può il primo
travestimento è molto comune tra le
ragazze diciamo che ho voluto mixare un
po di cose ho preso un tocco di catwoman
un tocco di ariana grande è un tocco di
gattina dolce e carina ed evento fuori
il mio travestimento hanno deciso di
chiamare arca tina che sembra un po tifo
in su targhettina va bene ma iniziamo
subito per la fit di questa mattina
sicuramente ho pensato a la pelle e al
colore nero quindi un pantacollant di
pelle nera deco pelle chiaramente che
abbiamo tutte in casa
sopra un topino nero un croato oppure lo
vado a prendere perché qui non sono
infilato un top di pelle che io ho
ripescato non so da quale armadio e se
fa freddo
se fa freddo cosa molto probabile
essendo parlamentare novembre una bella
giacca di pelle e anche quella cena
abbiamo tutte quindi un total black
ragazze poche parole un total black
un po di pelle e per quanto riguarda
l'auto se ma post
ok allora passiamo al make up è una roba
molto semplice riuscirete quindi a
realizzarla tutte e ci servono degli
ombretti scuri magari anzi sicuramente
uno tipo sul dorato di letterato così
eyeliner e palestre per il con touring e
eyeliner highline a sua volta iniziamo
stendendo sulla palpebra fissa un
ombretto scuro che può essere nero
marrone viola quello che preferite e che
avete a casa sulla palpebra mobile
invece applichiamo un ombretto dorato o
comunque glitterato sfumiamo bene il
tutto
dopodiché passiamo il nostro amato
eyeliner allora premetto che solitamente
sono più precisa ma mi sto guardando
come potete vedere in un mini specchio e
ho avuto qualche difficoltà
mi raccomando allunghiamo bene la riga
dell'angolo esterno per ricreare appunto
l'occhio di un gatto e per quanto
riguarda l'angolo interno
creiamo un piccolo triangolino poi
prendiamo una matita marrone o nera e
coloriamo la rima ciliare inferiore
per quanto riguarda invece l'interno
dell'occhio metto un po un goccino di
matita bianca e passò al correttore
stendo bene col mio beauty blend un po
di illuminante dentro appunto al
triangolino che abbiamo creato prima e
passiamo al con turi
dopodiché con un pennarello nero all
eyeliner andiamo a disegnare il nasino
del letto
coloriamo bene dentro
poi facciamo una riga che dal naso
scende verso le labbra ed infine andiamo
a colorare il labbro superiore e sempre
di nero con il beauty blender adoro del
brit due non andiamo ad applicare un
trucco d'acqua bianco intorno al naso e
poi disegniamo sempre grosso pennarello
i baffi e dei puntini e per finire
bellezza tinta labbra viola
ed ecco qua il nome è khan banchettino
per quanto riguarda i capelli
io opterei per una bella coda alta e ok
penso che pochi di voi ce l'avranno ma
io volevo mettermi la francia finta e
non so che mi piace di più
sapevo più della gattina e niente adesso
vi faccio vedere il total look this is
my outfit for all cantina e il secondo
travestimento è morticia addams
però questa volta partiamo dal metal
iniziamo cercando di rendere le nostre
sopracciglia un po più arcuate dopo di
che mettiamo in risalto gli zigomi con
un contouring bello marcato
proseguiamo assottigliando il naso
[Musica]
un po di correttore e passiamo agli
occhi
[Musica]
applichiamo un ombretto scuro nella
parte esterna dell'occhio e andiamo a
sfumarlo fino ad arrivare alla palpebra
mobile su quest'ultima invece
applicheremo un ombretto sul bianco
[Musica]
passiamo al nostro amato eyeliner anche
qui mi scuso per le imprecisioni ma come
detto prima non era facilissimo
guardarsi dentro quello specchietto un
bel po di mascara è una bella tinta
labbra rosso fuoco
qui e in particolare usato santa sangre
dica fondi eccoci qui il make up c'è ma
manca una cosa essenziale per il
travestimento di mortise a una bella
parrucca nera con la riga e mezzo mi
chiamo morticia addams e sono il vostro
peggiore incubo
ed eccoci qui questo è l'auspicio avevo
postato una foto tempo capo questo
vestito e mele che tutto è scritto ma se
privo di saddam si è infatti ragazze
l'ho comprato apposta così lo posso
usare in questa occasione voi ovviamente
se avete vissuto le frange non importa
se ci avete meglio però va bene
qualsiasi vestito nero tubino marika che
come volete
diciamo che molti e molto facile fare
perché tutti noi siamo pieni di vestiti
nei quindi sicuramente le prove rese uno
adatto e
passiamo al terzo travestimento eccoci
arrivati all'ultima travestimento
non voglio svelarvi nulla per adesso vi
dico solo che è un po più macabro degli
altri e che ci servirà come outfit un
vestito bianco
vi starete chiedendo ma cosa ci farà mai
con un vestito bianco
scopriamolo insieme a voi vi chiederete
perché si sapete dottor su bianco perché
visto truccando da vampira quindi devo
essere bella pallina magari anche un po
di occhiali l'occhiale lasciano fanno
sempre mood stendiamo un ombretto rosso
sulla palpebra fissa e proseguiamo
passando per l'angolo esterno
dell'occhio fino ad arrivare alla
palpebra inferiore
se volete possiamo aumentare l'effetto
occhiaia con dell'ombretto scuro che poi
andremo anche ad applicare sulla
palpebra mobile sfumiamo bene il tutto
anche qui non può mancare la eyeliner
cioè spaventose sì ma con stile matita
bianca all'interno dell'occhio tinta
labbra rosso scuro ancora meglio se un
po sbadata e un goccino di brillantini e
adesso arriva la parte più bella che gli
sangue il sangue il sangue aveva detto
che era un po chi marca però questa
volta il sangue che lamenti a un bambino
quindi il ciao volare dai lati proprio
come se avessimo appena ansa amato
qualcuno che bello fa paura ma un
bambino che si rispetti cioè anche i
venti affidata riesco parlare anche con
cover è differente non comuni terrestre
con nessuno tutta la serata
eccoci qua come sono classica parrucca
rossa fuoco e manca solo una cosa il
vestito e buona poi chiederete una cosa
ci fa con quel trucco e cogestito
ragazze ragazzi non sono solo una
vampira
io sono la sposa vampira e come tutte le
spose che si rispecchia anche il mio
fantastico velo non sono bellissimo
cambiamenti tanta gente eccoci arrivati
alla fine del video spero tantissimo che
vi sia piaciuto e fatemi sapere nei
commenti quale di questi tre
travestimenti avete preferito ma
soprattutto se decidete di scegliere uno
di questi travestimenti per la notte di
halloween
dovete assolutamente taggarmi nelle
vostre foto le voglio assolutamente
vedere
detto questo come al solito se volete
che vi saluto il mio prossimo video
dovete seguire queste semplici
istruzioni seguirli su instagram scrivo
di un direct message con scritto ciao mi
chiamo sarah salutari per favore nel
prossimo video e aspettare il prossimo
video e vedere se siete stati fortunati
e sensati dai tre innocenti che saluterò
se non avete ancora fatto seguite visto
tutti gli altri social instagram
musicali e facebook è aspettato un
attimo perché c'è un amica di vuole
salutare un secondino fischi
[Musica]